75 Cabernet for under 30 bucks that is  wine Tech's wine of the year  everybody asked me on DM on email what  wine should I buy for the holidays  what's that one wine need a wine for  Boss need a wine for a client need a  wine need a wine need a wine  I'm just gonna make it easy on myself  link is in the bio get it  that serious  you'll love it you should get a case if  you're serious wine lover like a Camis  Behringer private reserve Schaefer The  Prisoner if you like those big juicy  Reds  um  or if you just want to explore and get  into it a lot of you are getting on your  wine Journey For the First Time Link in  the bio check it out have a great  holiday